you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everybody thank you so much for
coming I really really appreciate it
I've been doing some very exciting work
and I'm really even more excited to
share it with you all today so I'm Alan
diapered I work at our studio like
Barrett I'm on the shiny team and I've
had the pleasure over the past few
months of working on this problem of
integrating react the JavaScript library
with shiny I believe that for quite some
time people in the shiny community have
been interested in react and about ways
to integrate with shiny and so this work
was initiated in an effort to bridge
that gap somehow and we've been at it
for a few months and we have work to
show which is why I'm here and why I'm
so excited but some questions and
problems remain unsolved and that's sort
of where you come in so I would
encourage you if you're at all
interested in any of this to follow up
with me afterwards that there may or may
not be time for questions but I'm always
happy to talk about this stuff and we
can you know talk shop and discuss why
you're interested in the context that
you're interested in because I think
that this could be the start of a really
fun and exciting little niche thing in
the shiny ecosystem so without further
ado let's start with a motivating
problem I guess a problem slash demo so
like many of you I'm online I'm on the
web I surf the web and you come across
things that are awesome and the only
problem with them is that they don't
have an HTML widget or they're otherwise
not accessible from our so one of these
things that I ran across was a react
based library called matte box GL matte
box is a company they make a library
called map out matte box GL which is
very similar to leaflet but it has some
interesting properties in particular
it's highly Thema bull so let me show
you some of the demos of this thing so
this is a very nice
leaflet esque map but of course we can
do heat maps pretty fancy and you can
switch between these the the thing
that's governing the the colors of the
roads and the city and county titles and
stuff that's all governed by one of
these map
style objects and then on the left hand
side here we've got the the heap of
JavaScript code involved in in rendering
that probably my most favorite one is
the Superman mode one where you
literally fly around right so just to be
clear I didn't make this but I think
it's awesome and this is the kind of
thing that I think gets you know gets me
excited when I am able to use it from
our so what I did is I in the course of
not too long maybe an hour or two using
the tools I'm about to explain to you I
was able to make my own HTML widget that
provides a subset of the functionality
we just saw and delivers it to us as an
our HTML widget and so I became aware
early in the conference that the most
important thing to keep in mind about
here in Austin or tacos so there's this
it's trending has been trending uh
someone named Caitlin who done I hope I
got that right who I haven't met
apparently posted on Twitter a list of
her five favorite places and then in our
studio person Thomas mock he made a
shiny dashboard using a leaflet map and
I thought hey in keeping with the
tradition of taco enthusiasm I should
make some kind of taco app so here we
are I've got some taco joints loaded up
into a data frame and I'm displaying
them with a data table here and then
over here I've got taco locations with
fork and knife sort of blurry little
icons and then probably the neatest but
also most awkward thing I can do is I
can filter this and after a little bit
of burping it comes back and you can see
that we filtered what shows up on the
map so like I said this is like an hour
or two of work now granted I'm like the
world's expert on this weird little
library here so take that with a grain
of salt but like I said I'm always happy
to help you use it so this is the
promise this is the kind of thing that I
think we can do more of if we develop
these tools that help us bridge the
JavaScript ecosystem particularly the
react ecosystem with shiny
flip back into PowerPoint mode here oh
yeah so there's some recordings in case
there were internet issues okay so this
is the all of the JavaScript code that I
needed to write in order to make go what
I just showed you if you know JavaScript
and are familiar with react you might
have a slight grin or even a smile on
your face if you don't know JavaScript
or don't know react you might be a
little worried at this point
but don't be I can assure you that the
things you see here can be learned
fairly quickly and a big part of what we
hope to do with this initiative is to
build out not just the code to do that
bridging that I mentioned but also to
build out the documentation and the
recommendations around learning
JavaScript leveraging its ecosystem and
all those things that surround
JavaScript development to make them more
accessible to people who are not who
don't have that experience so this is
the extent of the code that does the
adapting of the reacts library to show -
shiny world and yeah I think it's like
1111 lines of code I don't know does
this is anyone surprised at how small
this is or disgusted by how big it is
show hands hmm okay
my meme game is usually very weak but I
put this one in and it seems to have
gone well so alright so if you're the
kind of person who will would prefer to
ignore me for the next 15 minutes and
just start hacking here are the URLs you
need to know about we have a github
organization react - are and that's what
we call it because react without the -
are was was taken but if you go there
that's the organization there are some
example repos and then there's the react
our library excuse me package repo
itself and there's also a link to
various other pieces of tutorial
documentation at the bottom that will
take you directly to our tutorial which
as of right now is the best way to ramp
up on this topic particularly if you
have a little bit of JavaScript
background but if you don't have that
JavaScript background the rest of the
talk is for you so we're gonna talk
about what react is why it's interesting
we're gonna discuss the core unit of
composition and react the component and
how it's relevant to us I'm gonna
introduce you a further to this react to
our package and then I'm gonna describe
it a high-level the process I went
through to make that widget and then
I'll talk a little bit about what we
have in store for the future so what is
react well it's a JavaScript library for
making user interfaces it was invented
and faced at Facebook around 2011 I
believe they used it for the newsfeed
and then they bought Instagram and I
think Instagram started developed it
further and after Instagram had sort of
refined the idea or engineers at
Instagram rather they did a wide open
source release so it's a quite a mature
even though it wasn't open source until
2013 it's still quite a mature librarian
has been used thoroughly it supports a
functional approach I think if you if
you know how to write are you already
know what the functional paradigm is so
I won't elaborate on that but that's
another thing like react that's trending
in the JavaScript ecosystem but like I
said if you know are you're sort of
already on board so I wouldn't worry too
much about that paradigm or that word
and it's oriented around components I
mentioned that the unit of composition
in a react based application is
component and finally they invented a
syntax called JSX that you can think of
as a hybrid javascript and HTML syntax
and it really does make writing these
kinds of applications quite a bit more
concise and I show you'll seen some of
that in a second so I think you should
care about this for one of two reasons
one you did like what I just
demonstrated you're on the Internet you
saw something really cool you found it
and nobody's made the HTML widget yet so
you want to be the person to do it that
then that's a reason to be interested in
react it has a huge ecosystem with tons
of things that deserve to have their own
are wrappers and I see if everyone in
this class learns how to do this maybe
we could get a significant percentage of
the react ecosystem into our the other
reason might be you're coming from a
JavaScript development background you
have experience with react and you want
to build a react based library and maybe
add it to our mat adding it to our isn't
like an afterthought for you or would be
icing on top so that's another reason to
be interested in react if you want to go
deep on JavaScript oh I should mention
also that the reason to go deep on
JavaScript with react in particular is
this just wildly wildly wildly popular
and well supported by documentation and
communities and so on okay so react
components what are they very similar to
HTML tags honestly they are I think of
them as containers they contain data
hierarchically so it's sort of a way to
describe a tree the big difference is
that the HTML tags or elements are
defined by a standard the html5 standard
is the most recent one and there's a
closed set of tags and close set of
behaviors for those tags react
components are different because you can
define your own tags for components with
their own behaviors that are specific to
your library application they contain
something called props you'll see this
term in react documentation props are
basically a mapping or a like a named
list of keys to values and then they can
also contain other components again
because they're hierarchical and
applications are formed by composing
these into a tree of some kind and then
once you've finished composing your
components
it's Reax responsibility to take this
user interface that you've described
using react components and to display it
efficiently in the browser so this is
sort of the Minimum Viable hello world
of react from the adapted from the wiki
page Wikipedia page on react there are
four distinct code chunks these wouldn't
necessarily all appear in the same file
they could but they don't have to the
first piece we're looking at here is the
component definition so a component is a
Java Script class and here I'm using
newish JavaScript syntax and classes in
es6 and so that's that's what we're
looking at here it is JavaScript and we
can see we're naming a component called
greeter and then we can see that this
component extends something else called
react dot component and what we're doing
here is establishing a hierarchical
relationship we're saying this new class
greeter should inherit all the behavior
of the superclass or parent class react
on component there's only one required
method the render method and that method
needs to return something and in this
case this looks like a syntax error but
it's not we're in JSX that special
markup I mentioned so we're in a world
where there's a hybrid JavaScript XML
syntax at play so what this is doing is
effectively returning an instance of the
h1 component which is built into react
and then finally we're interpolating a
value into that JSX expression so if
you've worked with glue or other
languages that support they call string
interpolation that's kind of what we're
looking at we're slicing data from one
context into a template and this kind of
templating is another reason that JSX is
so handy here's some more JSX where
we're creating an instance of the
greeter class you can see the the less
than sign says we're creating a tag and
greeting is equal to hello world this is
the place where we assign those props I
mentioned that key value pairs
associated with an instance
of an element and then finally render
the whole thing to the Dom and the net
effect like if you were to right-click
in your browser or look at the elements
in the inspector you would see there's a
div called my app with an h1 hello world
oops so that's react in a very small
nutshell react dar is a package that has
been around since 2016 by a gentleman
named Kent Russell really nice guy and
his goal was to figure out ways to
incorporate react and JSX into shiny
applications and among other things the
package before we started working on it
it had react HTML dependencies react and
react Dom and so it is the canonical
place in the our packaged ecosystem
where react stuff is currently being
hung he also did something really neat
in his package he embeds v8 the
JavaScript engine to support JSX
tags or JSX strings inside our it's
pretty wild but it basically means that
you can write JSX without installing any
JavaScript build tools so that's a neat
thing and Kent's done a lot with that
the enhancements that I'm demonstrating
now have a more specific goal than the
original package goal which is to make
HTML widgets in particular easier and
the idea to do this it was either Joe or
JJ somebody in our studio before me
identified a symmetry between Reax API
and the API of HTML widgets and thought
huh we have an opportunity here to
bridge these two worlds and maybe an
elegant way or at least a way that would
prevent people from writing lots of code
so that the end the third goal is we
want to like I said prescribe and
support and document workflows and tool
chains for those who are not as
intimately familiar with the JavaScript
ecosystem so to make an HTML widget
using everything I just told you about
you would first scaffold in our package
with the use this package use this
amazing package it has a function in it
called create underscore package and it
will build out an empty skeletal package
then you can call react R : : scaffold
react widget while you're inside that
package you
just scaffolded and it will populate
with JavaScript build tool
configurations that we will support and
condone and then finally you do need to
install yarn and web pack on your
machine but once you do then you can
install these tools and they'll pick up
that configuration we generated for you
and at the end of the day you'll have a
minimum viable working HTML widget with
react in it we do have some remaining
work ahead of us so I would prepare you
as you as you begin on your react
journey that there are some limitations
currently we haven't figured out a
really nice way of sending data early
supporting widget authors to send data
from the browser context to the art
context this is not impossible right now
and in fact nothing I'm showing you was
impossible before my talk because all of
it really just was a factor of how much
JavaScript you were willing to write so
this is a case where sending values from
a react based HTML widget to are not
impossible but as of right now you're
gonna need to write some JavaScript that
relies on this existing shiny feature on
input change we made some interesting
prototypes to support this without
additional JavaScript and I think these
ideas hold some promise so over the
coming weeks days months we're gonna be
iterating on that and again this is why
it would be so awesome if you're
interested in this to get involved and
try it out and let us know what would
feel natural to you because at the end
of the day this is all about supporting
ease-of-use and accessibility right so
that's all the material I have prepared
I think I'll have a quite a few time for
questions I would like to make a special
thanks to Kent Russell who's been of
such a great package maintainer and
maybe I could call him a friend at this
point I haven't met him in person a lot
of emails but I hope he's cool with that
so thank you Ken thank you all very much
we do have some time for questions so
let me know and I'll throw you that all
right being somebody yeah this how we do
it okay it's funny when you go to a talk
and it covers something that you already
we're dying to learn about so thank you
very much
sure however the problem is that I have
a similar mapping library sort of
application but it's from view how I'm
not sure how to phrase this how much
work is it to create this react or
package and do you think it's very
likely that something would be recreated
for view so great first of all great
point
second of all we should hang out maybe
we can be friends
third we think very highly of you within
our studio and I say that's kind of the
collective because I don't have personal
experience with it but we have several
experience reports internally and of
successes we chose react initially
because there was already an existing
package and someone in the community we
could work with on it and because there
it seems like I could be wrong but my
impression is there are far more
available libraries in react world than
in view world as of this moment I could
be wrong about that but that's kind of
my impression is that on point or
Oh No right so to answer that specific
technical question I think there are as
few if not fewer technical hurdles and
view as they're on react I think I
mentioned the symmetry between HTML
widgets and react I believe there is
that same symmetry based on what I know
right now between HTML widgets and views
so it's it's something we've identified
and we really want to do at some point
in the future thank you
[Music]
hi I had a question about there's a
library that you guys have called
crosstalk I'm not sure if you're
familiar with it yes what it does is if
you have some data that you want to
filter on the front end you can add a
plot Li and you can add a data table and
you can add some dropdowns and it does
all of those filters very quickly for
you on the front end I don't know if
work is being actively done on that
package but when I was looking at the
stuff you were doing with the react I
was wondering if that sort of front and
filtering and aggregation is something
that you guys have planned for a reactor
so we haven't worked on that
specifically but it is one of our goals
to be what I think of as well-behaved
members of the HTML widgets ecosystem
there are some cases where we're gonna
sacrifice capabilities for ease of use
so I mentioned that there's a lot of
scaffolding involved to get people going
quickly
I think crosstalk is one of those cases
where it would be very difficult for us
to meet to to scaffold the general
approach so JavaScript would be involved
but it's certainly not something we
would rule out or otherwise make
impossible so it would always be
possible it just may involve more
JavaScript when they showed yes yeah
would there be any limitations on the
react components as to compatibility for
example something that you know does too
much in react that you wouldn't be able
to port
excellent question yes so we made some
cuts there in the inch again in the
interest of ease-of-use there are
certain things you can do in react that
don't really follow from the model that
we advocate we we settled on the model
we have because it's a set of
conventions for interrupting with react
that seemed to work for
majority of libraries there are those
edge cases and when you hit the edge
cases it's kind of like the crosstalk
story it's sort of you need to you need
to know JavaScript then at that point
but again when you do get to that point
our goal is to at least have examples
and documentation to support you as you
go that direction in JavaScript world so
that it's never totally inaccessible to
you that you identify while you're
building your widget that that's a step
you know abridging need to cross and
then we're there to hold your hand at
least while you while you do that
[Music]